hey who turned out the lights
overdue Doctor Who review and this one
as per usual brought to you by the radio
versus the Martians podcast hosted by
Mike gills and Casey Doran they have a
rotating stable of guests and they talk
about all manner of pop culture
geekiness from the mainstream to the
niche they'll talk star wars to
wrestling to Batman to the Hoover of
Arnold Schwarzenegger it's fun it's free
and it's worth checking out
radio versus the Martians calm or
wherever you get your podcast so I've
been waiting for this one silence in the
library and the forest of the Dead this
is one of my favorite modern era stories
I think this two-parter is phenomenal it
has my favorite modern era companion it
has the introduction of River Song and I
know not everyone likes River Song I do
and I especially loved her introduction
I think the story is cool it's got a lot
of neat twists in that and big as it
goes about and I really like the mash
tun in a rod I like the concept of them
like the way they executed the way
they're explained this is just really
really good and yes this is mostly gonna
be me gushing I do have some net picks
to be fair but yes mostly gushing so
first of all the library is a awesome
setting a place is just nothing but
stacks and stacks and stacks of books
that's a great setting especially for
something with a slight horror twinge to
it because if you've ever been in a
library when it's empty or feels like
it's empty it's a little eerie it's a
little spooky I mean that I like to
think there's a reason that that opening
scene in the original ghost burst
ghostbusters happens in
a library I just I think it works really
well for that so we've got the doctor
and we've got Donna wid they're awesome
banter I'm pretty sure this is the first
instance of us noting that the sonic
screwdriver doesn't work on wood and
Donna you know catching her her little
observations of about the world like
realizing that the exit' would be near
the Little Shop they were in because
they always put the little shop near the
exit and but then she gets sort of taken
out of the story and she gets her own
little sub thing going on which okay I
always understood that that was sad like
even when I saw this for the first time
but you know being a parent now and
watching Catherine Tate break down when
her children fade from existence because
she doubts that they're real man oh man
she nails that it is heartbreak there's
actually there's a number of stuff about
this episode that chokes me up there is
that oddly um I don't remember choking
up with this before I choked up a little
bit when the data ghost is getting
explained with what is left of Miss
Evangelista and Donna sort of reacting
to that and trying to help her you know
just talk her through her last moments
and yet like Donna I think in the past
when I've talked about Donna I've talked
a lot about you know how good her banter
with Tennant is about how quick-witted
she is about how snappy and sassy she is
and she is all those things and
fantastica being them but honestly Donna
is an endless well of empathy it's
really impressive she goes out of her
way to understand the people that they
run into more than Tennant does I think
more than a lot of other modern era
companions I mean you wanted to compare
her to say rose Rose would sometimes act
like the other people that they would
- were interrupting her adventure where
is Donna like she she makes these
connections and you can tell that it
hurts her sometimes Mike would miss
Evangelista but that's what makes it
powerful
so that stuff was really great and yeah
rivers good bye chokes me up more so now
that you know I I've gotten more time
with her and I can now view this
properly as the end of her story even
though it's the earliest one the doctors
timeline is the end of hers and it's you
know what it is in that moment it's when
he says time can be rewritten and she
snaps at him not those times not one
line don't you dare
because she would rather die than lose
that and that even the hint that he
might undo that oh no but she's still
terrified ask his stuff and I'll since
I've kind of gotten there naturally
we'll transition off of Donna will talk
River I think this is a terrific
introduction to her and as far as her
whole premise Anor whole deal of meeting
the doctor out of order this establishes
it really well she's got good banter
with Tennant she is flirty but not
excessively so there's like a handful of
moments that are overtly flirty but it's
not laid on quite as thick as it is
sometimes in her later appearances but
there's all its it's sort of undercut
with a layer of sadness here because
this this is the time that she's been
dreading that time that she sees the
doctor and he doesn't see her he doesn't
know who she is and she's never had that
and all the time she's known him he's
always recognized her and this is the
first time that he doesn't know her and
she asked she gets hit with that you can
see it in her performance oh that's
really good it's got a really good
supporting cast as well which the best
two partners do that's not to say that
there aren't
you know single up so stories that have
good supporting cast but in my
experience most of the best supporting
cast are in good to partners because it
gives you more time to get to know them
characters like Anita and other Dave and
even Lux honestly I empathized with him
by the time the story's wrapped up now
and even characters who like don't even
show up until the second half like Lee
McAvoy in Donna's whole sort of
otherworldly thing or you know who else
is great in this Colin salmon is doctor
moon first of all I don't think I put
him on my list of actors who'd be really
good to play the doctor he would he'd
make a really good doctor like seriously
Colin salmon is really great in general
but he's good you know the little girl
is good does a very good job of sort of
playing the exasperation of a child I am
gonna come back to some of that stuff
though because that's where some of my
nitpicks come in um but oh there's the
passion in errata and I've said before
they should never be brought back and I
stand back by that and yes I understand
they've been used again I think in like
some novels or whatever fine whatever
but I don't want to see them back in the
show I'm okay with them appearing again
like in a novel or in Big Finish or what
had because that's a fundamentally
different medium and I'd be kind of
curious to know how that gets expressed
in a non visual medium but I know how
they work on the show and I don't think
they'll ever be as impactful as they are
here and they work really really well
and it's such a cool concept and I I
will always adore the line from 10 and
when River ass every shadow goes no but
any shadow which is actually scarier
because if it's every shadow could kill
you like or if it's every shadow would
kill you then you know you're looking
around going well I'm just screwed but
if it's any shadow could then that
brings all this uncertainty into it and
that is way scarier of having to make
the decision to step into across the
shadow and not
no if you just signed your death warrant
or not that is good that's a nice nice
touch tenants really on fire in this one
too playing so much his confusion ever
sorry the way his face Falls when she
whispers his name in his ear you again
yes see the impact of that on him or and
I've complained about this as a general
thing and as a moment before but I do
love here in this episode him facing
down the Vashta Nerada and saying I'm
the doctor and you're in the biggest
library in history look me up because
that whole thing of the doctor turning
people away at the mention of his name
it it works for me less often than it
does when I look at all the times that
happen and I dislike the overuse of it I
don't like how declarative he often is
about this sort of thing but I really
love this moment because it feels much
more like a last-ditch attempt as
opposed to him coming in and assuming
that his name is going to inherently
change something and also he doesn't
just say his name and they're like the
doctor he's like no look you have the
resources you have the resources to look
at everything ever written and ever
recorded connect the dots figure out who
I am it's not that his reputation
preceded him which is what tends to
happen in the later instances were
things like this are brought up it's
that he says look you have access to all
the information realize who you're
dealing with
so it's not just his raw reputation and
I think that's the thing that bugs me in
in other instances so that works for me
here as well and the music is great and
this has got one of my favorite and
possibly my favorite all-time Doctor Who
track which is the greatest story never
told it oh man there's just there's
almost too much good stuff to talk about
but I did say that I had nitpicks so I
will mention a few of them the there's
one that is fairly nitpicky and there's
one that's more substantive
then they pick you one of the way first
there's a few too many instances of just
lines getting repeated over and over and
over again and it's not like it's trying
to hammer an exposition or anything but
between the the the suits with the
people who got devoured by the Vashta
Nerada and they have their loop there
one looped line of dialogue so between
that and between like alerts from the
computer system and then with like the
faces on the snow so like the very end
of the first episode kind of exemplifies
this as you've got this hey who turn of
the lights Donna Noble has been safe hey
who turned out like Donna Noble husband
say and there's just layering on top of
each other and like it goes on too long
like if it had been condensed into like
half the time that it kind of runs that
it would have felt like oh my god all
this stuff on but it just keeps going
he's like yeah no we got it we got it
could just stop so that's a little
annoying but the more substantive
complaint I have is about the young girl
in the computer so it's not about the
concept down with the concept it's not
about the performance from her she's
solid it's not about the ins and outs
and the logistics of how this plays out
no I buy it is if it's going to
basically function like a young girl's
mind filtering it through a dream logic
at times in order for her to accommodate
all these other people cluttering up her
headspace no that works that makes sense
here's the thing that bugs me so at the
very end
Lux says how his grandfather this was
his youngest daughter and he couldn't
save her body so he saved her mind and
used her as the basis for this computer
and he you know he put her there and he
gave her every book ever to read because
she loved books you know it's one thing
we never saw her do and her little
domestic home life that I guess is the
interior of the computer never saw her
read a book
she colors talks with dr. moon talks
with her dad she watches TV she never
picks up a book like it's very strange
to me that the core concept of what she
is is like she was this young girl who
loves books but we never see her reading
a book like I'm not saying that books
necessarily were gonna be able to be the
whole thing because I do think enough
sort of depends on her use of the the TV
remote control that it would have been
hard to come up with a book equivalent
but honestly just like why couldn't she
like at one point she's coloring and the
TV come and the like the phone starts
ringing why couldn't she be reading why
is she coloring why isn't she reading
why does it like the TV come on and she
sees the the people on there like and
it's interrupting her reading just sure
with a book uh that that really doesn't
know because like I feel like they
really missed a trick on that and it
feels like a going plot hole it away I
know it's not really but like that one
really annoys me but I say really it
obviously doesn't ruin the story for me
cuz I love this story I love the pace I
love the cast I love the sense of fun
and adventure yet the threat and the
fear it is all just wonderfully
intermingled in this terrific
self-contained story that also sets up a
character who's gonna get to be
recurring and have a larger story across
the whole thing and yet at the same time
in this introductory story it still
feels like a complete experience I love
this two-parter
and even with nitpicks
this is just epic silence and librarian
force of the dead you seen it would you
think about it whatever your thoughts
were drop something down to comments
let's talk about it there's a whole
bunch of stuff to do down there as well
cuz there's buttons and links and you
can subscribe and support me on patreon
etc etc etc so links down below check
them out click on them they'll take you
all sorts of places but you also don't
have to like I definitely appreciate it
but I'm not gonna tell you what to do
because at the end of the day you're the
council
I'm just running the meetings so until
next time this council is adjourned